let's talk about Mordecai working with
Johnny Depp yeah in Mordecai you guys
have a we're actually seeing a little
bit we have a very racy dance we do we
have a very racy dancing we I got it fun
working with him it is so much have you
met Johnny before yes yeah yeah do you
like him yes I mean what are you gonna
do say no not really a deaf guy myself
he's so nice Jesus he seems like a very
nice guy especially in Martin but still
a dick fingers going with that now I'm
good but it's a cool feud yeah you yeah
that's a real cool few yeah no one's
gonna take my side of that views I'm
gonna say yeah I wonder who'd win yeah I
don't like Johnny Depp who that's a
pretty lonely time for me I'll just be
rolling his cigarettes over in the
corner yeah yeah no no it seems like a
good guy yeah he's a great well
especially like in a lot of like then
that big dancing there's a scene worth
at the end of everything he's got to
touch my breasts every time and just
like hold his hand there what he wait a
minute what was that all about
um it was in the script it's one of
those sure it was or heavy pencil was it
in pencil and it looked a lot like his
handwriting
it wasn't crayon it was big crayon the
letter touch food you gotta be real some
chonies like hold on one second about
about being in movies they get anywhere
else in the world you just can't meet
hey how are you and then touch your boob
but he thing like hey it's on this
script like okay yeah it says it here
it's the job yes you touch it yeah not
part of this job I'll tell you right now
but if you're an actor they get too mean
get to have to ha ha I'm married I find
other women repellent yeah keep talking
to me yeah it's important so you do this
number we're gonna show it right now but
he was a gentleman about it the whole
time and also everyone says when they're
in these situations that they get used
to it that that's just the work right
you know is Johnny Depp's got his hand
on you it's just the work right no I
don't always feel so low odd yeah I
don't think it is maybe for him it was
work over and over but for me it's still
like you're there and everyone's looking
at you and and then he's just got his
hand on your breast and it's just
strange yeah you know I I just want my
boyfriend I think that's it and it's
very strange and some other guys doing
you have to kind of get used to it in
your head over and over right right but
in a fun way
yeah like you're gonna see in the clip
yeah it's a rosin upsetting yet
glamorous yeah
it was a really horrifying time for you
let's take a look oh let's look at have
me oh maybe I haven't so tired so
married and it's so tired well I don't
know what that's my bottom you're going
in for the kiss and I know it's more of
a smoked it's not so much a honey it's a
blackboard course Oh Andy knows that
smell well all right
this show will never air
you